citizens of the reject Nation it is at last
time to not only make a new common corner
hello and thank you for coming back and being
so excited for this but also to break down the
DC slate by excitement I love making these
lists to you guys and I know there's gonna
be a lot of stuff we're going to talk about
that slate but I thought first of all let's
do broad Strokes just what we're the most
excited about so please do let me know in
the comments which one that you're the most
excited about which announcement you thought
was the most surprising what your order of
excitement is and now all of this could change
because we've literally got nothing except the
shape of the story via tone announced by comic
which made me very happy and the announcement
itself so this isn't what's going to be best
when it arrives it's what level of excitement
we're at right now from these announcements now
we're going to focus on the 10 new announcements
we knew about the Batman 2 very excited to get
the title in the release date but we're not
including that one we're just doing the 10
new properties please do leave a like subscribe
hit that notification Bell and let's get into it
first up number 10 my number 10 is the Creature
Commandos now this one is just on the lower side
because this is not a property I particularly
have a lot of investment in a lot of connection
to I was only vaguely aware of it existing I
I had heard of it but I didn't really have a
lot of context it's an early 80s comic and it's
about World War II if my memory serves and it's
animated now I am excited for the animated two
live-action Crossover with the actors I think
that has a lot of potential I think them saying
that is a very strong seed planted but I generally
connect to live action more than animation and I
generally connect to characters whose books I've
read that's the only reason this one's number 10
but something had to be last number 10 Creature
Commandos coming in at number nine is Paradise
Lost now this could conceptually land with the
Paradise Island Lost comic book that's a two issue
story arc that's very solid but it doesn't seem to
be so I think the reason this one's so low for me
is I really love the character of Wonder Woman I
think she's the third of the Holy Trinity of DC
and without knowing what place Wonder Woman has
in this the mascara story I can't put it higher
that yet this one has probably the most potential
to go from number nine to my top three because
like I said I do love Wonder Woman if this is
a soft origin for a Wonder Woman show if this
is launching Wonder Woman's own corner of the
universe any of those things this could really
work for me but as far as just the mascara as a
westeros-esque world as a Game of Thrones s thing
I'm not as big into Game of Thrones as most people
I really am enjoying house the dragon actually
more than Game of Thrones but I I don't know
if that Dynamic is going to sell me as the rest of
this slate so depending on how this sets up Wonder
Woman depending on how this sets up the amazonians
depending on what the flavor of the story for this
Westeros de mascara is time will tell but for
now it is number nine Paradise Lost coming in
at number eight and things are accelerating now
we're into the like where do I put this I'm so
excited number eight is Waller now Peacemaker was
one of my top three shows of last year Peacemaker
is a force of nature of telling vision and I
really think that what Peacemaker was able to
prove is that there is no character irredeemable
to James Gunn I loved his The Suicide Squad but
I definitely found myself going like yeah I love
the dichotomy and Duality between Idris Elba and
John Cena but that's what sells me on Peacemaker
is he's that exception he's the outside and then
the show showed me oh my God not only is John Cena
a Powerhouse actor but the way that James Gunn can
make me care about anyone I immediately loved
all the Guardians of the Galaxy I immediately
loved the characters because of their underdogness
but Peacemaker is not a great dude in The Suicide
Squad and then they are able to give him texture
and flavor and build all those things out I think
that's what we're gonna get with Waller I think
Viola Davis is I mean it's Violet Davis I think
Amanda Waller is a character we've only seen
as like this very intense badass authority
figure I think if they add some layers to her
we've already met her daughter we'd have some
you know mother-daughter moments I think you
can really grow Amanda Waller in her own show
and I think the idea of a peacemaker spin-off is
incredible very excited about all the the pieces
of the puzzle but I don't know how involved James
Gunn is and he is a key factor for my enjoyment of
Peacemaker I think his ability to make us love the
unlikable character is a huge factor and I don't
know how much he's involved in this show so while
I'm excited to see Waller grow as a character
while I'm excited to see The Peacemaker World
grow out this has to be on the Lower Side just
because I am concerned about the Cameo elements
of working in a show in a universe that's just
starting with this character and with perhaps me
just wanting more of a peacemaker season two and
three and Beyond and because my next seven are
would be in the top 10 of most years lists so
it gets uh very hard to decide between A's and a
minuses going forward coming in at number seven is
the authority The Authority is probably my biggest
surprise of the entire announcement other than one
comic specifically being named later on but the
authority is a wild storm comic in my mind it is
a comic that's a imprint of DC and was kind of
merged with DC but what makes this interesting
is wild storms The Authority was a commentary
on the Justice League there are literally two
members of this that are pretty much one-to-one
parallel commentaries on our two biggest heroes
in the Justice League Batman and Superman are
midnighter and Apollo it's literally the god
of the sun Apollo midnight or Dark Knight but I
don't think there's ever been a universe where
the commentary on the character is in the same
universe as the character I think the closest
might be Deadpool because he's kind of a a play on
Spider-Man but he's not a commentary in Spider-Man
it's different there's a meta awareness there that
isn't as present here because Deadpool's kind of
like a mix between Spider-Man Wolverine um Snake
Eyes like those characters whereas this is what
would these characters be in another world it'd
be like a Superman red Sun was in the Saint Peter
versus Superman so I'm very curious about the tone
of this I'm very curious about how they're going
to make this work in world because again it's not
an else world it's in the DCU so I'm very excited
to see an anti-justice league in the Justice
League and there's a reason I put uh Waller
and the authority together because I do think that
Waller is going to lead to the authority I think
that's it's not coincidence we're getting
a Waller comic book this year that deals
with wildstorm I think that the authority Waller
combo is going to go right into each other and I
think we're going to build out a very interesting
anti-justice League that again is going to be very
dissimilar from The Suicide Squad much like we've
got Thunderbolts and the dark Avengers and Marvel
I think the anti-justice league and The Suicide
Squad are gonna have some interesting commentaries
on what that looks like and I'm very excited for
it coming in at number six is a property I have
waited years for lanterns we are getting a lantern
show now this would already be very high up on any
most anticipated of the year list but the fact
that James Gunn specifically said True Detective
True Detective season one is probably one of the
best seasons of Television of all time hardstop
I was gonna quantify that but it's literally
I think one of the best seasons of TV so if
you're going for that tone and you're setting
a terrestrial Green Lantern world with they I
think they described it as a substation Earth then
you've got a very interesting thing afoot because
he said the mystery inland interns is tied into
the whole DCU so this could be a big bad they're
leading to at the end of chapter one this could be
uh maybe like the anti-life equation this could be
something that ties into the greater universe that
these detectives these space cops have to solve on
Earth add to that we finally get Jon Stewart in
live action add to that we haven't had Hal Jordan
but once really in live action and that wasn't the
greatest thing it's kind of a cautionary tale of
superheroes I think that this show on HBO is
going to be a huge weekly Conversation Piece
I loved one division because it was a mystery
I loved True Detective because it was an adult
mystery this might give us the opportunity for a
superhero adult mystery conversation show that we
talk about every single week that has the [__]
Green Lantern core this is so exciting number
five Booster Gold Booster Gold is so ripe for
today I want to make a whole video about Booster
Gold I might but I really think one of the most
interesting things about this is that we're living
in an age where where social media is everything
and it's only exponential and by the time 2025
rolls around and this show comes out it's going
to be so much worse than it is now and this is a
character from the future that comes to today to
be cool this is an unlikable not the greatest guy
that grows into a hero his first Arc in the comic
books is kind of an anti-hero Superman's trying
to figure out where he came from he hides the
fact that he's from the future because he wants
to seem like he has powers he has Tech from the
future that basically gives him Powers today but
I love that commentary on futurism on tradition
on what makes a hero on anti-heroes on basically
being a hero for likes does it make you a hero if
you're only helping people for popularity does it
make you a good person if you're only commenting
on things negatively to get likes does it make
you good if you're yelling into the void about
not enjoying certain comic books and certain
properties to get more likes on Tick Tock viewer
I don't think it does and so Booster Gold kind of
represents giant insecurities and trolling but to
a superhero scale there are so many people that do
this that talk about especially comic books and
movies that say Really really ignorant stuff to
get attention I love using a superhero to turn
that on its head and yeah I got a hundred things
to say we gotta do a Booster Gold Video if you
want to see a Booster Gold video I got a lot to
say leave a comment below very excited about this
character to get the live action screen treatment
number four Batman the Brave and the Bold we're
getting the bat family we're getting a version of
Batman we have not seen in a very long time the
furthest we've gotten in live action Batman with
the bat family was Robin and that was in the very
tricky to navigate Schumacher movies and I think
the drill Schumacher movies could have been very
special I think Joel Schumacher is a very very
talented director but I think that was a time
when Studio involvement was so much so that it's
basically to sell toys now we're living in entire
age where the the actual IP matters we're living
in an age where Batman himself matters where
people are lobbying for a dick racer people are
lobbying for a Tim Drake where people are are
wondering is Jason Todd gonna be the Red Hood
these are characters that are known and loved now
they're not just things to sell toys and so living
in an age where the bat family is known living in
an age where we've been wanting this so badly and
living in an age where I think the best strength
of this property is in the fact that Damien Wayne
is a bit of a monster and thus has to change
Bruce Wayne and thus has to make him a little
bit lighter is a beautiful way to set up the
dichotomy between this Batman and Pattinson that's
how you're able to have two Batman in one slate
we're in 2025 we're looking at having two Batman
right now we've got so many we've got Michael
Keaton we've got Ben Affleck we got you know
been we just had bail we've got Pattinson but it's
going to be two very different Batman and not only
does that show the strength of the character but
it allows them to exist simultaneously and show
why there's so many Batman comics and we get the
bat family and we get characters we've wanted to
see on screen I again will talk a lot about that
in another video but Batman is going to be very
different very soon and that is is very exciting
for fans of the Pattinson and the Neil Adams and
the the fun 66 take a like coming in at number
three is Swamp Thing now this one is really hard
to even quantify I think the reason I'm so excited
about this one is if they hit the mark this is
doing Watchmen right this is making Sandman for
Netflix correctly this is the potential to make
something that's so avant-garde and existential
but also horrific but also full of heart the comic
book they showed is a Swamp Thing winter special
which is a pretty recent Comics Tom King and it
is a love letter to the writer who invented it
while also being a commentary on mortality and I'm
protecting and on safety and on what it means to
be human while dealing with a non-human character
and there's so much magic and mysticism inherent
to Swamp Thing there's so much interesting lore
there's so much mythology Swamp Thing can lead
to just slick dark or not Swamp Thing can lead
to entire mystical worlds this is is as big of an
opening as Dr Strange to an exponential scale this
is as big of an opening to a new world as when
James Gunn did Guardians it changes the potential
for everything and if they can set this up as a
horror story that also has all of these very deep
heady thoughts that we're in for poetry the movie
this is a beautiful poem of a character and I
honestly think this could be the most interesting
and experimental comic book movie we've ever seen
if it's handled right and I'm hearing it might
be James Mangold uh he posted a picture of a
very stunning Bernie wrightson uh piece of Swamp
Thing art and that to me it's like 1201 by the way
like two days ago like the night at the Slate uh
he posted a Bernie writes in piece and I'm like
I don't know why James I mean maybe James Manuel
is just a fan but I wanted James mangled can you
imagine slither's producer in James Gunn and the
director of Logan and James mangle doing a Swamp
Thing very high potential for this beauty very
excited coming in at number two and this is 100
percent event going to be another video breakout
as well because this is a conversation I've been
wanting to have for quite some time and I've been
having it uh you know with my friends and I've
been having it uh briefly on Twitter but I want
to dive into it and that is why we need a new
Superman and this is going to be Superman Legacy
and the art used is Frank Whiteley beautiful
stunning cover art from All-Star Superman written
by Grant Morrison one of the most hopeful powerful
colorful uplifting Superman stories in years I
have been very on the record for saying how much
I love Henry Cavill I have been very on the
record for saying how much of a bummer it is
that the cost of this reboot seems to be Henry
Cavill but honestly I do think Superman Legacy
will show us the importance of the character to
the world it's so hard to even say this without
sounding cheesy but that's kind of the fun of
Superman is he can be cheesy but he's so good
that works and that is this this is the statement
Superman can make the world better and I want a
King Superman movie that makes the world better I
want people to look at this this figure this this
pop culture icon and want to Aspire to be better
and we have not had that in a very long time and
when Superman was invented the world was very dark
and he was a commentary on Hope and getting out
of the darkness and right now the world is very
dark I would like a character to pull us out of
the darkness so yeah I'm I'm literally calling on
Superman to save us and bring back truth justice
in the American way and I honestly think if
handled right it's a very important movie on
not just a movie scale on a worldwide scale we
need Superman frankly and I'm very excited for
this take and my number one most anticipated of
that slate Supergirl I honestly I like Supergirl
I really do I think she's a fantastic character
but I also find her to be a character that is very
very hard to write a lot like her cousin Superman
but one of the arcs that I love most one of my
favorite comic book arcs of any character not just
Supergirl but in comic books is Supergirl woman of
tomorrow and they are directly not inspired by
not in regards to not lovingly they are adapting
Supergirl woman of tomorrow and it looks like I'm
pretty sure it's confirmed Tom King is writing
this this is Tom King adapting his comic book
to the screen this is one of the best writers
in comic books making a screenplay out of this
this is Tom King who was supposed to be working
with New Gods way back in the day finally making a
movie and this is a guy who was a an agent for the
states he worked for the CIA who then wrote one
of the best Batman of all time who then went on to
make my favorite DC Comic of all time Mr Miracle
who then went on to redefine in my mind Supergirl
and Superman and if he's directly adapting his
own story that redefines Supergirl for me in a
way that is a commentary on what it's like to be
isolated alone what it's like to feel alien what
it's like to have these Powers what it's like to
be a hero what it's like to do the Dirty Work what
it's like to help someone do something you don't
want them to do because you'd rather shoulder that
bird burden this could be all of that in Star Wars
this is a giant sci-fi space epic this the scope
of this is magnificent and wonderful and powerful
and the morals and themes and human element make
it so so important while being so stunning and
beautiful the art in this book is transcendent the
story in this book makes you a better person and
the way you connect to Supergirl a character again
that I like but don't know to love is so impactful
this could make a character that a lot of people
don't give the time of day into an a-lister this
could make a character that a lot of people see as
like oh girl Superman no no Supergirl is her own
thing and that's the point of Supergirl living
in her cousin's Shadow how do you live in your
cousin's Superman Shadow and be a hero this is
beautiful and the fact that she's on her own at
the beginning of her life she like was born on an
asteroid the isolation the underdogness honestly
I I I'm gonna talk I'm gonna make 100 videos we're
gonna make so many videos about this late but
that is my number one pick I am very very excited
for Supergirl I love woman of tomorrow I highly
recommend you read it it is an eight issue Mini
series I'm gonna give you some comic book Recs
actually right now Supergirl one through eight
woman of tomorrow it is uh last year I think 2020
it started 2021 and ended maybe 21-22 check it
out eight issues Tom King I would also recommend
highly if you're interested at all in uh any of
these characters I would say that you could dive
into some weird stuff with Swamp Thing I think
the Alan Moore stuff is very very important go
back to the Lynn ween stuff if you like the Alan
Moore stuff there's something called American
Gothic that's a pretty solid collection that I
think would suit you I think if you want to check
out anything with the authority it's a linear you
can just get one through twelve like and then if
you like that you can go on to the next but it is
a linear path you don't have to read a bunch of
comics it is it is one Journey with the authority
because they're a commentary they're not in the
world yet they do get in the world Superman comes
in you'll see but I'm very excited about all
that also that's a good point Superman coming
into the authority was very interesting because
of that commentariness them just jumping into
the DCU fascinated but those are my top 10 most
anticipated by hype by excitement what are you
you most excited for let me know in the comments
below which of these was your most surprising what
is your order I like lists I'll read your list and
uh overall what are you thinking 2025 is going to
look like by the time we get there for superhero
Cinema and what do you want to see the difference
of the TV shows be either way talk about this
slate a lot if you want to see more of this let
me know what else you want me to talk about in the
comments below you guys are my co-host I tell you
what you want to hear about it's up to you let me
know in the comments you want more comic wrecks
let me know you want more stories let me know
thank you to you reject Nation we'll see you soon